hey everyone my name is David Makovsky
and I'm a solutions engineer with the
Google Maps API team so as a solutions
engineer i work with google's top
customers and partners to help them
solve their business problems with the
power of the google maps api s so as
Monica and Paul mentioned location
intelligence has become increasingly
important to businesses of all sizes but
only now are they really available to
businesses of any size so so you don't
need to be an uber or an Amazon to take
advantage of location intelligence any
startup any company can take can build a
platform on Google Maps through the
google maps api so i'm going to tell you
a little bit about some of the API is
that Paul showed you on the previous
slide how they can be used in a
real-life situation so I'm going to show
you a demo today that demonstrates how a
small company can use location
intelligence this is a fictional call a
fictional coffee delivery service called
coffee pot I'm going to show you how
they could use the API is to drive
better engagement streamline their
operations and deliver a more status
greater satisfaction to their customer
base okay so coffee pop what is coffee
pop so this is a small again fictional
coffee and cake delivery service I
stress fictional because last time we
had people trying to download the app on
their phone and were coffee and I wasn't
wasn't working out for him so coffee pop
they brew coffee out of Brewster trucks
they have a bicycle riding workforce
that delivers coffee and cake to people
at their own location on demand and then
they can move their bursted trucks
around to better optimize their service
area to to maximize the number of
customers so therefore they need to
connect their customers writers and
delivery trucks together in real time to
keep everyone informed about current
operations and the itinerary and allow
management to keep an eye on the entire
operation so to do this they've built
three separate applications one for the
customers one for the writers and one
for the managers so what does the
management team do so they have a nap
too
view and improve the real-time
performance of their entire operation in
real time the customers have an
application so they can place an order
for coffee and cake at their location
and then the delivery writers have an
appt so they know when there's an order
ready and to get routed to the customer
so I'm going to show you how each one of
these applications can be built with the
Google Maps API s all right so this is
our management dashboard so this
provides a view for management into the
entire operation of their business so we
have things here on this dashboard like
customer satisfaction scores the number
of active orders the percent of orders
that are late or behind schedule I can
see recent feedback and someone says
three stars my coffee was on time
someone says one star you or three
minutes late I can also view a map so
this map gives me a live real-time view
into everything that's going on in my
delivery sound so what I have here in
the middle this icon here represents my
brisket truck this is where we're
brewing the coffee so I can click on it
and I can view our entire delivery
service area so this polygon here
represents it's what we call an
isochronous everywhere you can drive
within 15 minutes in this case so we
want to set up a delivery zone in real
time to ensure that all of our customers
can be service within 15 minutes so
we're using real-time traffic data to
generate this in real time let's look
some of these other icons of what they
represent so here we have a delivery
writer I can click and zoom on him so
this is one of our bicycle riders and I
can view what his current task is so
he's right now tasked to go pick up
coffee at the Bristol truck and then
deliver it to this customer over here I
can also see these icons you see the
little happy faces and if i zoom yeah
there's some frowns over here these are
customers that have already been
serviced but are either you know happy
or unhappy so I see over here I have a
couple unhappy customers so then I want
to dig down and try
to investigate why why were these
customers unhappy where that was their
orders wrong or maybe they were late and
I can bring in other layers of
information other sources of information
should try to analyze what went wrong
here and better understand the situation
so one thing I can do is I can turn on a
real-time traffic layer right here in
the app and I can view real-time traffic
conditions to see if maybe that's
impacting our service in this area maybe
I need to change our service area a
little bit so the next thing i want to
show is now what the coffee pop
experience looks like from the
perspective of a customer from a mobile
app so here i have a iOS application
this is built with the Google Maps SDK
for iOS and in this case what the
customer would be doing and interacting
with this experience is is dragging the
pan around here to indicate where they
want their coffee delivered to typically
this is just going to be their existing
location so we get the location from the
device and say this is where I want the
coffee deliver to but perhaps you know
you're on your way to the park you're
and you want your coffee delivered there
so you can move the map pen now the
interesting thing here is the number you
see here at the bottom of the screen so
this is the time estimate now a lot of
things are going into this time estimate
it's the amount of time that is going to
take the delivery rider to get to the
bris the truck the amount of time is
going to take to process the order and
then get that order over here to the
customer and so it's doing an assignment
from the orders to the delivery writers
in in real time and in automated fashion
behind the scenes so there's no
dispatcher here involved this is all
just happening in an automated fashion
so now that I know my time estimate I
can click to place my order i can say i
want some coffee some cake and click
confirm it's been assigned to a delivery
writer i can see a map I get a time
estimate and I can click order now and
then now I can monitor in real time that
delivery driver as they come
deliver me my coffee so I can see what's
going on here
okay and then I will not show you the
third application so this is the
application that the delivery writers
would have with them on their mobile
phone so in this case this is an android
based application using our android api
so the first thing that it would do is
detect that the delivery writer is
inside one of the active bursted truck
delivery zones and once it is once that
writer is there they're allowed to sign
into the application and instantly
they're matched up with a job that's
that's waiting for them so they can
accept the job and they can view the the
active job and in this case it doesn't
necessarily make the most sensors to be
assigned to one to the great job it
could be several so you want to go to a
brissa truck pick up several orders and
then deliver them all so our directions
API is being used here behind the scenes
and what that's doing is actually doing
Waypoint optimization so it's routing
them in the most efficient route to
these multiple destinations they can
view the first they need to select a job
back to be the job yes it's doing a
variation of the Traveling Salesman
problem so in this case it's 11 worker
and up to we can do up to several dozen
waypoints and this it's not just doing
them you know hundreds or thousands of
void points which becomes very
computationally intensive but with a
smaller subset yeah we can do that so so
with the drivers giving a route and then
was giving the set of direction co2 and
do those multiple deliveries and when
the deliveries are done you can mark
them as as complete or what you can do
is actually use the location from the
device itself so if it is actually
traveling around it could detect that
the driver has entered into the same
zone as the customer location i said hey
that deliveries we made mark those jobs
as as complete so
this is just a few of the ways you could
take advantage of the google maps api to
build out an entire business in an
automated fashion so it doesn't require
much infrastructure it doesn't require
servers as a required data centers we
built this all in the cloud with just a
few applications and and really power
your business location